اهلا بكم مشاهدينا هل باتت واشنطن حقا
بصدد تغيير موقفها من النظام السوري
السؤال يفرض نفسه على ضوء تصريحات
لمسؤولين امريكيين هي الاكثر وضوحا وحده
تجاه الاسد لا سما بعد الهجمات الصاروخيه
التي شنتها القوه الامريكيه على قاعده
جويه سوريه في الشعيرات بمدينه حمص اثر
مجزره خان شيخون التي استخدم فيها السلاح
الكيميائي ضد
المدنيين خلطت المندوبه الامريكيه لدى
الامم المتحده الاوراق في محاولت توضيح
الموقف الامريكي من بقاء الرئيس بشار
الاسد في سوريا على نحو يزيد المشهد
اراكا فبالنسبه لهيلي اصبح اخراج الاسد من
سوريا من اولويات اداره الرئيس دونالد
ترامب وفي نفس الوقت تلمح في مقابله مع
شبكه سي ان ان الى ان بقاء النظام ضروري
للقضاء على تنظيم الدوله ثم تعود لتقول
انه لا يمكن التوصل الى حل سلمي ما دام
الاسد يحكم سوريا يتداخل هذا الموقف
الاخير مع تصريحات لوزير الخارجيه
الامريكي ريكس تيلرسون يقول فيها ان مصير
الاسد على المستوى البعيد سيحدده الشعب
السوري وقال الوزير الامريكي في مقابله مع
محطه سي بي اس الامريكيه انه بعد هزيمه
التنظيم يمكن ان يتوجه اهتمام بلاده الى
اعاده الاستقرار في سوريا مضيفا ان ذلك
يتطلب مشاركه النظام ودعم حلفائه على حد
تعبيره فاي حجم تعطيه الاداره الامريكيه
لازاحه الاسد وهل تعبد هيلي بهذه
التصريحات الطريقه امام بقائه في الحكم
كواقع سياسي ينبغي التعامل معه ام ل
تحييده قد يكون الهجوم المفاجئ الذي شنه
الرئيس الامريكي على مطار الشعيرات في
سوريا بعد الهجوم الكيميائي الذي استهدف
خان شيخون وخلف عشرات القتلى ومئات
المصابين قد يكون وهو الهجوم الذي حظي باش
الاغلبيه من الجمهوريين فرصه للاداره
الامريكيه للخروج من هذا الغموض وتوضيح
موقفها من بقاء بشار الاسد من عدمه في
السلطه لكي لا يصار الى القول انه كان
مجرد رده فعل انيه
ومنفردا هجوم مطار الشعيرات حتى وان كان
محدودا في الزمان والمكان حسب التصريحات
الامريكيه الرسميه قد ينظر اليه كمنع جديد
في التعامل مع الملف السوري فيما لو تبعته
مواقف واضحه لاداره دونالد ترامب وهو امر
لم يحدث بعد قرئ في تصريحات المسؤولين
الامريكيين غياب معالم واضحه لاستراتيجيه
ترامب في التعامل مع الملف السوري وفي خضم
هذه التطورات يتموقع عدد من اعضاء مجلس
الشيوخ الامريكي في موقف لا لبس فيه من
بشار الاسد فقد تقدموا بمشروعي قرارين
يعتبران فاقدا للشرعيه ويدعوان لمحاسبته
ويحملان المسؤوليه عما وصف بجرائم حرب
وجرائم ضد
الانسانيه القرار ذاته يدعو مجلس الامن
الدولي لاتخاذ اجراءات فوريه وحاس ردا على
استخدام الاسد الاسلحه
الكيميائيه ويبقى السؤال عن مدى تاثير
وفاعليه هذين المشروعين في حال اقراره ما
من قبل مجلس الشيوخ على الموقف الامريكي
من الازمه السوريه خاصه انه في جانب منه
يدين روسيا الحاضره بقوه في سوريا بسبب
عرقلتها الدائمه والمتكرره لقرارات مجلس
الامن بما فيها قرار استخدام السلاح
الكيميائي انضم الينا لمناقشه هذا الموضوع
من واشنطن كل من الدكتور محمد الشرقاوي
استاذ تسويه النزاعات الدوليه والسياسات
العامه في جامعه جورج ميسون ولاري كورب
كبير الباحثين في مركز التقدم الامريكي
ومساعد وزير الدفاع السابق معك ابدا سيد
لاري كورب كيف يمكن ان نفهم حقيقه موقف
اداره ترامب من النظام السوري ومن الرئيس
السوري تحديدا في ضوء تلك التصريحات
الضبابيه والمتناقض احيانا للمسؤولين
الامريكيين ليس هناك تصريحات ناه بعد
الهجوم ولكن حتى قبل الهجوم وحتى قبل
استخدام الاسد للسلاح الكيمياوي كان هناك
من يقول اننا سنترك الاسد في السلطه
والسؤال يبقى ماذا نتوقع الان هل ان هذه
الخطوه ستتكرر اذا ما عاد الى استعمال
السلاح الكيمياوي ام لا طبعا لماذا
استهدفوا هذا المطار قالوا انه استخدم
الطائرات لتنطلق من ذلك المطار لكن ماذا
عن بقيه الاسلحه التي لا تقل فضعه في قتل
الناس اعتقد ان الغموض ما زال والتشو ما
زال باقيا حتى بعد الضربات الامريكيه نعم
لكنك قلت
بانه الامور كانت واضحه ولم يتغير شيء اك
كان قبل الضربه او بعدها لكن المعروف ان
الاولويه كانت واضحه لهزيمه تنظيم الدوله
في س سوريا اما الاسد فبقاؤه او عدم بقائه
يقرره الشعب السوري هكذا كان يقول وزير
الخارجيه الان بعد هجوم خان شيخون وبعد
هذه الضربه اصبحت الاولويه هزيمه تنظيم
الدوله وازاحه الاسد هل هذا يعني انهما في
نفس المستوى من الاهميه للاداره الامريكيه
وبالتوازي
لا ارى الامر كذلك ما لم يقوموا بما هو
اكثر من الضربات التي وجهوها ضد المطار
العسكري الذي انطلقت منه الطائرات لاسقاط
الذخيره الكيمياويه لان النظام استخدم نفس
المطار من قبل لقتل الناس باسلحه اخرى
وطبعا اذا ما ارادوا عمل المزيد لابع
الضربات الاولى بمزيد من الضربات لكنهم لم
يفعلوا ذلك طبعا الرئيس ترامب قال
للكونجرس انه كان فقط يرد على استخدام
السلاح الكيميائي ولم يقل شيئا عن مصير
الاسد سيد دكتور محمد الشرقاوي هل ترى ان
هناك انعطاف او بدايه انعطاف للسياسه
الامريكيه وللموقع من الرئيس
الاسد كلا لان ما حدث يوم الخميس باستهداف
في مطار شعيرات لم يكن ينم عن استراتيجيه
متكامله الان في موقف البيت الابيض وان
كان وزير الخارجيه وايضا مندوبه امريكا في
الامم المتحده يشيران الى ما يفهم انه نوع
من توجه في هذا الاتجاه ما حدث هو مجرد
ضربه تكتيكيه كان الرئيس ترامب بحاجه
اليها للاعتبارات الداخليه اكثر من
الغايات الخارجيه هو الان على مقربه من
حوالي 20 يوم
من فتره المئه يوم الاولى في البيت الابيض
وبحاجه الى ان يعدل الكفه كفه الانتكاسات
والفشل في اصدار مجموعه من التشريعات
باسمه في الكونجرس فهو استثمار سياسي
واستراتيجي في هذه المرحله لكن لا يبدو ان
هناك نيه حقيقيه الان ناهيك على ان البيت
الابيض لازال يبحث عن امكانيه بلوره
استراتيجيه للقضاء على داعش ما نلاحظه
الان هو مجرد اجراء مرحلي بمعنى ان هناك
جدليه فعل دمشق ورده الفعل من البيت
الابيض الانتقال الى الخط دتور هل يمكن ان
نتجاهل هنا التصريحات التي صدرت عن مندوبه
الولايات المتحده
في الامم المتحده وايضا هل يمكن ان
نتجاهل تصريحات ريكس تيلرسون فيما خص رئيس
النظام
السوري اعتقد الصوره هي مركبه على يمينها
الرئيس ترامب بصحو الضمير
وبالاجبار قد الضاحيه المدنيين وفي يسار
الصوره هناك تيلرسون وهناك يهيل الذين
الذان الان يرفعان لواء الواقعيه ويلوح
باستخدام هذه القوه ينبغي ان نستحضر ان
هذه هي تركيبه الخطاب السياسي لحكومه
ترامب لكن هذه الاقوال ليست بالضروره
بمحض ما تمليه اي استراتيجيه التي لم
تتحدد بعد يبقى ترسن ونيك هيل هما من يكرس
هذه الواقعيه السياسيه لكن ينبغي ايضا ان
نشدد على ان صاحب القرار في اي اجراء
عسكري هو الرئيس ترامب والاكثر من هذا هو
الان ايقض انتقادات المشرعين في الكونغرس
ممن يطالبونه بالحصول على ترخيص من
الكونغرس قبل المغامره العسكريه في الشرق
الاوسط في منطقه اخرى فينبغي ان ننتبه الى
ان اداره الازمه ازمه سوريا في هذه
المرحله وايضا محاوله ترامب الفصل بين
حقبته وبين حقبه سلفه اوباما التي كثيرا
ما ينتقدها هي ما اوحت له باتخاذ ذاك
الاجراء العسكري المحدود بمعنى انه كرس
القوه لكسر قدرات دمشق على استخدام
الاسلحه الكيميائيه ولم يصل القصف الى ضرب
السلاح الجوي او يعني توجيه ضربات اقصى
الى النظام في دمشق سي سيد لاري كورب هل
يمكن ان تكون هذه الضربه هي نقطه البدايه
ل الانعطاف انعطاف اداره ترامب تجاه رئيس
النظام السوري
واتخاذ موقف اساسي بضروره ازاحته عن
السلطه
يمكن لها ان تكون كذلك لكن لا توجد مؤشرات
على ذلك وكما قال زميلنا في البرنامج اذا
ما ارادوا تقويض قدرات الاسد كانوا بامكان
بامكانهم استغلال هذه
الحادثه عنده ست قواعد عسكريه كان
بامكانهم ان يدمروا خمسا منها او يدمر
قدراته الاخرى العنصر اساسي هنا سيكون
الروس يبدو لان روسيا لم تكن سعيده
باستخدام الامريكيين للقوه لكن طبعا لو
لكنهم لم يفعلوا ذلك لدرجه الغاء زياره
وزير الخارجي الامريكي ترسن وطالما انهم
لم يفعلوا ذلك ربما سيكون هناك نوع من
الضغط الروسي على الاسد لكي لا يعود الى
تكرار فعلت هذه وربما الدخول في شيء من
الحوار لحاله من الانتقال السياسي وتقرير
مستقبل الاسد مستقبلا لكن مره اخرى لا ارى
هذه الضربه العسكريه كجزء من محاوله
استراتيجيه كامله لتغيير نظام الاسد كما
يود البعض ان يروا ذلك ا دكتور شرقاوي
فيما لو كان هناك
بالفعل تغيير في موقف اداره ترامب تجاه
ازاحه نظام ال الاسد هل يمكن ان تفكر
الاداره القيام بذلك بمعزل عن الحوار
والتوافق مع
روسيا لا يمكن ان نتصور اي اجراء اخر من
حجم اكبر اتجاه سوريا دون التوافق بين
الكرملين والبيت الابيض وايضا ينبغي
التشديد هنا ايضا على الفرق بين اداره
الازمه السوريه ومحاوله تسويه الازمه
السوريه سواء الاعتبارات انسانيه او
الاعتبارات
استراتيجيه الان الرئيس ترامب كل ما يقدمه
هو مجرد بعض الاجراءات التي تحكمها
الاعتبارات الداخليه في الولايات المتحده
اكثر من تحقيق غايات اخرى او الخروج عن خط
موسكو او التمرض على الوضع الذي خلفته
دبلوماسيه لافروف وكيري لاكثر من عام فلا
ينبغي لا ينبغي ان نهول في تاويل دعنا عند
مستوى التفسير لا اعتقد الان ان البيت
الابيض ينظر في ما يمكن ان يشكل البديل
لنظام الاسد لان ترامب من الاساس وان كان
يستخدم التدخلات العسكريه يظل من دعاه
الانعزاليه السياسيه امريكا اولا ولا يريد
الان ان يدخل اي في اي مغامره اخرى الاكثر
من هذا انه حتى ربما تكلفه الغارات يوم
الخميس حوالي 75 مليون دولار قد يفكر في
من سيدفعه على غرار مطالبته المكسيك بدفع
تكاليف الجدار العازل المرتقب فينبغي ان
نقلل من سقف التوقعات من مدلولات هذه
الغاره يوم الخميس شكرا لك دكتور محمد
شرقاوي استاذ تسويه النزاعات الدوليه
والسياسات العامه في جامعه جورج ميسون
وشكرا للاري كورب كبير الباحثين في مركز
التقدم الامريكي ومساعد وزير الدفاع
السابق